how do you balance extreme ownership
with holding others accountable for
their actions and avoiding them using
you so this is actually a question that
I end up responding to on a fairly
regular basis and there's really a
couple different angles here that are
going on the one of the the points here
is the balance of extreme ownership
versus holding others accountable and
what that really means and or what
another way of looking at that is it's
really extreme ownership versus
decentralized command so decentralized
command is it's one of the laws of
combat that life and I write about in
the book decentralized command and what
that means is everybody leads that means
everybody's a leader and that's what you
want and that is a that is a the
complete opposite of extreme ownership
so extreme ownership I'm that I own
everything
decentralized command is I'm gonna let
everyone else lead so there's a real a
real contradiction a real dichotomy
there so what you have to do is balance
it you have to balance it's the only way
to to sort of rectify or ret or
reconcile those two opposing forces
because you do but you do have to have
extreme ownership of everything that is
true and at the same time you have to
have decentralized commander because you
can't be everywhere at once and you have
to let your frontline leaders lead so
you have to balance them so that's one
part of it is that you should if you
feel yourself for instance if you feel
like you can't get everything done and
you're losing control or you're you're
not able to execute everything because
there's too much on your plate it means
that you're not delegating enough it
means that you're not your frontline
troopers aren't stepping up and leading
now so you've gone too far in one
direction now if you're leaders or if
all of a sudden you're having to tell
your leaders like eh
you need to get this done hey what are
you doing why don't you take an
initiative then that means you've gone
too far in the other direction so you
have to find the good balance and that's
the that's the goal and again and I'll
say it over and over again that's what
makes leadership hard leadership the
hardest thing about leadership is that
there's opposing forces that you have to
balance and if you could just pick the
extreme and go with it and that made you
a good leader anyone could do it but
it's not it's it's the balance that
makes you a good leader it's the balance
that's challenging so now the other word
so that's part of the question the other
word is accountability in holding people
accountable for their actions now this
is where I'm gonna throw something out
that people are not going to expect me
to say because people always talk about
accountability and I hear that all the
time in businesses and they say yeah we
really need accountability
accountability accountability and here's
the issue I have with that you don't
want to have to rely on accountability
accountability is actually a crutch
it's a tool and I'm not saying you never
use it because sometimes you do have to
use it you have to implement it if
people aren't doing what they're
supposed to do you have to hold them
accountable but I will tell you this
what you what you don't want it's people
that are doing their job only because
you're holding them accountable that's
not what you want you want people that
take initiative and ownership of their
job and they do it not because you want
them to or because you're going to
inspect them they do it because they own
it they take extreme ownership of it
that's what you want so if you were to
ask people that work for me if I held
them accountable and they would be like
mmm not really
I mean for instance weapons inspections
so you know I'm in charge of a platoon
or I'm in charge of a task unit
and there's you know a couple hundred
weapons or whatever a bunch of weapons
and if you don't take care of those
weapons and people don't maintain them
and clean them and lubricate them
properly they can rust very easily
mm-hmm and so we know one of the things
that you may have to do is do weapons
and inspections to make sure that my
guys are cleaning their weapons and I
can tell you I rarely if ever conducted
actual weapons inspections the reason my
guys my guys did it
my guys owned it my guys wanted to be
the best they wanted to always have the
best possible reputation and so I'd have
to go around inspecting their weapons
because I knew that they were gonna do
it I knew that that my guys who were on
board who understood why we were doing
what we were doing mm-hmm who understood
that we wanted to be the best and who
were on board with trying to be the best
said you know what you know we are gonna
make sure these weapons are the best
possible and I learned this when I was
in my second platoon my boss was an
awesome guy and this is a guy that I've
talked about before he was a huge
influence on me he was a prior enlisted
SEAL who became an officer he was a
combat veteran from the warned Renata
and he was a very humble guy and he's
actually the guy that inspired me to
become an officer because I said to
myself well this guy's this guy made our
lives so good maybe I could do that for
16 guys in a platoon someday but what I
realized about him is he never held us
accountable for anything but at the same
time he infused accountability on us
because what we wanted more than
anything else was to do a good job for
him and for the platoon that's that's
how you get true
and teams aligned not by holding them
accountable when the imposed
accountability but where they are
inspired themselves to hold themselves
accountable and you had a coaching call
with a team the other day that was they
were saying hey you know we really we
really we would like to have you you
know
coach us because we're lacking in these
areas and we really need we know what to
do but we really need someone to hold us
accountable to do it hmm and I was like
lesson I charge a lot of money and you
guys would be stupid to give it to me
you guys just simply lack the discipline
to work for the team and make it happen
and I threw this example I said you know
if you were competing against another
team and what I did was I moved into
your house and I woke you up in the
morning and I held you accountable for
what you were supposed to do and I made
you do it so we put the ultimate in
accountability on top of them I said who
would do better you guys with me waking
you up in the morning and beating you
until you accomplished what you were
supposed to do I held you to the up the
highest standard of accountability or a
team that was hungry themselves that was
gonna go the extra mile that was gonna
do more work that was gonna stay up
later that was gonna get up earlier not
because somebody was holding them
accountable but because they had the
desire for victory who's gonna win that
contest and the answer is very simple
those with the innate and intrinsic
desire to win will win over those that
have imposed discipline and
accountability put on top of them now
because there's a dichotomy to
everything and because there's a balance
to everything there are times where in a
leadership position you do need to
inspect and make sure that you hold
people accountable and an example I have
that is we had when we got to Ramadi we
had our radios and generally the radio
men
knew how to program the radios and and
get them synched up so they could talk
to other radios and all that and I told
the guys I'm like listen everybody in
the troop needs to know how to program
your radio yourself and if it says oh
okay
and it was so critical that they know
how to program these radios because if
you're out in the field and you get
separated from your unit and all of a
sudden your radio gets zero eyes or it
has a problem and you don't know how to
fix it yourself what are you gonna do
you can't talk to anybody and you're
doomed
you're gonna die so because it was that
critical I actually after the first
briefing I called a couple guys up and I
said give me a radio and I zero eyes
their radios and I said okay reprogram
it now and a couple of them didn't know
how to do it and I said okay listen up
guys
no one is going on operation if you
can't reprogram your radio and so the
guys had to sit down and go and figure
out how to do it so there's times where
you you do have to hold people
accountable and in that situation I knew
that even though I was saying hey it's
important they didn't realize how
important it was because you know it was
all you got to know how to work your
gear they kind of took it like that
I knew that guys didn't really
understand the nature of how important
it was to be able to operate and
reprogram your entire radio and sync it
with the army radios and all that I knew
that they didn't quite understand how
important it was and so I had to I had
to hold them accountable but generally
ninety-eight percent of the stuff I
didn't have to hold people accountable
I didn't inspect things I expected
things and they delivered yeah and and
that's that's people will follow your
lead if you take ownership that's how my
guys have always been they've always
seen that and and known what the
expectations were and finally if if
you're sitting there and you keep saying
here so if I gotta hold people
accountable I gotta hold people
accountable most likely you don't need
to hold them accountable you need to
lead them you
to make them understand why they're
doing what they're doing why it's
important how it impacts the strategic
mission how it impacts the team how it
impacts them that's leadership non
accountability its leadership
accountability is just a tool and it is
a a it's a crude tool compared to real
leadership so use it if you have to but
try and use leadership instead